Ciao mi chiamo Pega era l'unica frase
che sapevo in italiano
varcata la soglia della porta della
quarta elementare entro in una classe
dove non capisco nulla
nulla
ero con uno zaino più grande di me e in
braccio un dizionario italiano iraniano
iraniano italiano non arabo
e iniziavano a farmi delle domande un
po' strane
e non capivo il perché tipo
Ma tu Quanti cammelli avevi in Iran
e io dicevo Ma io non ho mai visto un
cammello in vita mia
primo giorno non è andata bene Torna a
casa piangendo mamma papà che ci
facciamo qui perché mi chiedono dei
cammelli
a 9 anni scopro cosa sono gli stereotipi
era il settembre del
ero molto arrabbiata con loro perché non
capivo perché eravamo lì perché avevamo
cambiato casa perché avevamo cambiato
paese
perché non sapevo cosa era successo nel
luglio dello stesso anno
8 luglio 1999
una delle date più sanguinose che gli
iraniani conoscono molto bene
his Day tir
dopo la Chiusura forzata di una rivista
riformista
Salon
Gli studenti hanno iniziato a fare delle
manifestazioni pacifiche ma sappiamo che
ad ogni azione corrisponde una reazione
uguale o contraria e nelle dittature è
sempre contraria
hanno circondato le i dormitori le
università hanno iniziato a picchiare e
torturare ragazzi 70 studenti spariti
nel nulla 1500 ragazzi arrestati 20
morti
erano in cucina i miei genitori quando
stavano parlando
e dicevano Dai un giorno capirà
ed è vero
l'ho capito
ho capito perché eravamo lì ho capito
perché ero in salvo
anche mio fratello Purtroppo
un piccolo genio della musica che non
aveva il permesso dalla televisione
Nazionale iraniana di esprimersi
musicalmente aveva solo 5 anni ed era
stato censurato perché faceva muovere le
persone
Allora mi sono un po' vergognata di
essere iraniana e mi sono iniziata ad
allontanare dalla mia cultura dalla mia
prima cultura
non volevo più parlare in persiano
ero diventata quella con il nome strano
che sapeva parlare l'italiano meglio
degli italiani
ero felice
in una nuova casa stavo bene
finché nel novembre del 2006
ero felice fino a quel momento perché
arriva a casa
mamma papà
andiamo in gita scolastica andiamo a
trovare la regina Elisabetta
i miei genitori imbarazzati mi
guardarono e mi dissero Amore mi
dispiace ma tu non ci puoi andare
perché
perché non hai la cittadinanza italiana
quindi un ennesima
barriera da superare
Allora mi sono avvicinata alla mia
cultura prima cultura alla mia cultura
di base
ho iniziato a raccontare le nostre
tradizioni la nostra lingua o anche
insegnato le parolacce ai miei amici
per avvicinare per far capire che
effettivamente io ero come tutti gli
altri
quando sono andata in classe e ho detto
il motivo per il quale io non potevo
andare in gita
tutti i miei compagni mi dissero Ma tu
sei come noi
Eh lo so ma evidentemente non per lo
stato
poi mi divertivo a raccontare e dire che
dall'impero persiano era arrivata
nell'Impero Romano sono diventata
un'ambasciatrice poi della cultura sia
italiana che iraniana
e con grande orgoglio sempre parlato
della patrimonio immateriale e materiale
perché questi due mondi in realtà sono
molto più vicini di quanto si pensi
ottobre del 2009
decido dopo la scuola di iscrivermi alla
magistrale in ingegneria di
l'architettura
no non riuscirei mai a superare il primo
anno perché esce da un linguistico non
potrai mai superare le materie
scientifiche non sei brava
ho superato gli stereotipi culturali
Vuoi vedere che adesso lo stereotipo di
genere possa fermarmi e quindi sono
andata avanti sono diventata
rappresentante degli studenti al Senato
accademico poi consiglio di
amministrazione ho aperto
un'associazione e poi un collettivo che
trattava proprio questi temi di violenza
di genere
violenza visiva psicologica
economica e digitale perché tutti gli
stereotipi che abbiamo di base culturali
sociali li riversiamo Nel digitale e
possono essere molto più discriminatori
delle persone stesse
e poi c'è anche un'altra discriminazione
su quello digitale
non in tutto il mondo sia accesso a
internet non in tutto il mondo siano
accesso alle piattaforme non in tutto il
mondo
si può raccontare quello che si fa ed è
quello che succede in Iran
Allora ho iniziato a
collaborare e connettere sempre più
persone in un intelligenza collettiva
perché volevo che tutti capissero Cosa
erano tutti questi limiti che in realtà
non erano limiti
erano solo pregiudizi
stereotipi ma facilmente abbattibili
settembre 2022
un altro ostacolo
la mia paura la mia paura di parlare
dell'Iran da un altro punto di vista
da quello che ho sempre saputo ma non ho
mai detto
per paura di non tornare più in Iran per
paura di avere dei problemi e di causare
dei problemi
mamma papà
questa volta le manifestazioni sembrano
diverse le cose vengono chiamate con il
proprio nome a morte Il dittatore
avevo molta paura
è stata una scelta molto importante
molto difficile
amore
Fai quello che è giusto fare
ho fatto il primo video in cui spiegavo
perché in Iran c'erano con le
manifestazioni E perché doveva succedere
dopo 44 anni di repressione
Il video è arrivato a 170 mila persone
allora ho capito che c'era bisogno da
quel giorno non ho mai smesso un solo
giorno di parlare dell'Iran
in tutte le istituzioni scolastiche
universitarie politiche aziendali
sapete cosa è stato di più
il ricordo di mia madre
mia madre stava litigando
fortemente con la polizia morale io l'ho
attaccata alla sua gamba mio fratello in
braccio La volevano portare in caserma
Per lo smalto rosso
per fortuna non c'è andata siamo tornati
a casa
Allora mi sono fatta incoraggiare
soprattutto dal coraggio che arriva
dalle ragazze e dei ragazzi in Iran che
a mani nude
affrontano la polizia
c'è il video di una ragazza
famosissimo quel video
dove lei avanza con il sorriso
e 10 poliziottinanti son mossa la
iniziano a manganellare per strada resta
lì
Ma la sua immagine sarà eterna ed è
proprio grazie a quel sacrificio
che ancora adesso anche in queste ore
stanno manifestando
nella bellissima e straordinaria
rivoluzione donna vita libertà
[Applauso]
queste donne
shirtzan le leonesse
sono il vero motore di questa
rivoluzione è vero
E se non fosse per loro probabilmente
anch'io Non sarei qui a parlarvi di
questo
e di tutto il resto di tutto quello che
ho sempre fatto ma che adesso ha un
senso
Darda
il mio dolore è diventata la mia
medicina
sapevo e avevo messo anche in conto
le
intimidazioni le minacce i bastoni tra
le ruote
ma non mi fermano e lo sapete perché
perché io ho questo
sono in un paese che mi permette di
parlare
sono in un paese
in cui ho il diritto di scrivere
raccontare la verità
e sono libera di viaggiare di muovermi
da Sanremo
al Festival di Sanremo sono entrata
nelle case nel cuore di tanti Italiani
ho ricevuto anche
l'incoraggiamento alle parole del
Presidente della Repubblica
fino al Parlamento Europeo
il Parlamento Europeo c'è ed è anche
quella casa mia
racconto nelle storie che ogni due
giorni sono in un treno
è diventata quasi una barzelletta
È molto faticoso non è facile
Ma lo devo fare Non solo perché dovere
morale senso civico
soprattutto perché
Tutti devono sapere cosa accade nel
mondo e non è solo la rivoluzione in
Iran prima o poi sarà anche un altro
paese tutti Saremo chiamati a rispondere
perché facciamo parte di un'unica grande
famiglia che la famiglia umana
e quando mi chiedono il perché
[Applauso]
Perché lo fai piega
perché
perché una missione
perché non voglio
che tra 50-60 anni venga detto che nel
2023 c'era la possibilità di cambiare il
mondo e non l'abbiamo fatto
e il senso dell'umanità
È questa la cosa che mi spinge ad andare
avanti
e vorrei ringraziare tutte e tutti che
tutti i giorni mi scrivono mi dicono
Grazie
E io ringrazio voi che siete l'energia
che mi permette di andare avanti
e non mollo
e invito anche voi a non mollare
e non essere indifferenti
ma essere umani Grazie
[Applauso]